oh
derniers visiteurs avant la fermeture du
biodôme le public assiste à une scène
hors de l'ordinaire
on leur apprend présentement à tolérer
le toucher pour faciliter les
manipulations lors du transport
c'est comme un call en avant le départ
le grand jour est arrivé pour les
manchots royaux
pas facile de quitter sa maison quand on
y vit depuis 25 ans certains ont besoin
d'un petit coup de pouce
d'autres sont plus stressés a tancé la
pape
ouais c'est bon
[Musique]
l'été est lacunaire tous les manchots se
demandent où ils s'en vont
la réponse est au zoo de calgary les
animaux seront accompagnés tout le long
du voyage par la vétérinaire et mikko -
et un avion qui est passée puis toutes
les royaux en fait comme ça c'est
vraiment drôle
les manchots raison de s'intéresser aux
avions car il se dirige vers l'aéroport
de mirabel
c'est évident saion animal dada et mikko
est vigilante
pas question de perdre ces animaux rares
menacées d'extinction
[Musique]
une fois à l'aéroport les manchots
deviennent rapidement l'attraction
principale inévitable
peut-être son industrie
[Musique]
durant tout le vol
la vétérinaire sera assise à côté des
pilotes et pourra se rendre dans la
soupe pour surveiller les manchots
[Musique]
au zoo de calgary les manchots sont
accueillis comme des stars on s'attend à
au moins un an et demi d'adaptation pour
les femelles
je pense pas qu'ils vont revenir chez
nous est en année leur âge avancé
donc j'espère qu'ils nous fassent lait
pour bébé confuse potentiellement
présenté au public au biodôme en 2019
retour au biodôme
c'est au tour des paresseux de déménager
ce mal prend la route du zoo de
cleveland et une femelle s'en va à celui
de granby passera pas mauvais de la
suivre de près le biodôme espérait que
la femelle s'accouple avec un autre par
esso du zoo de granby
mais ce sera impossible car ils sont de
la même famille un oncle et sa nièce
c'est très fréquent de fin des échanges
et c'est dans l'intérêt de pouvoir
poursuivre la reproduction des espèces
qui sont menacés il n'y a pas d'argent
qui est impliqué dans ce genre de
transaction là
[Musique]
l'équipe du biodôme n'en a pas terminé
avec les manchots il en reste des
dizaines à déplacer les vétérinaires en
profite pour examiner les gorfous doré
maire une des choses à laquelle les
manchots sont sensibles c'est les pattes
j'espère la forme avec les manchots sont
stressés ils sortent très rarement de
leur habitat certains tentent même de
s'évader
la majorité des pensionnaires sera
relogée dans les sous-sols l'espace pour
la vie un tout nouvel habitat temporaire
leur a été construit les manchots semble
intimider de découvrir leur nouvel
espace
c'est un peu ce qu'on peut trouver
l'artiste yen qui fonctionne bien pour
les manchots et évidemment on voit
procurer la neige en enrichissement
réduire nos très rapidement les manchots
prennent leurs aises et profitent de la
piscine spécialement creusés
durant les dernières semaines le biodôme
aura déménagé des milliers d'animaux des
petits aux plus gros un défi logistique
et un stress pour eux comme pour les
humains
à l'intérieur du biodôme les espaces
réservés aux animaux sont devenus bien
calme jusqu'à l'été 2010 9 et le retour
de leurs admirateurs hisser thomas
gerber radio canada montréal